[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in dan orlowski covers
football for espn one of our favorite
analysts uh what do you make of this
story there that brady and gronk almost
had a pit stop in las vegas therefore
john gruden now getting credit for
two super bowls for tampa one when he
was a coach and the fact that he didn't
sign tom and gronk and let him go to
tampa hey
what a wild story it's it's interesting
because everything you ever heard about
john gruden is his favorite quarterback
is the next one
and the fact that if there is validity
to the story that
um
you know he had the opportunity to not
only bring brady in
but also with gronk is shocking that he
would not have
had that come on board i would love to
hear mike mayok's opinion on it too
because mike was running the team as a
general manager at least so
um you know tampa bay's benefit do i
think that brady would have won the
super bowl in in las vegas like he did
in tampa no because that roster wasn't
nearly as good um but i i mean that's
shocking that he didn't take advantage
of that but that means brady when he was
referring to you're going to stay with
that mf er
it's derek carr
that makes sense
yeah sure i think uh i think every
quarterback outside of like maybe a
handful
you know probably um
can can kind of be called or reference
that by brady and not take offense to it
um
so if he was saying it about like rogers
or something it's probably different
connotation but derek carr while being
really good um tom brady obviously a
massive upgrade
uh full introduction here for dano uh
tonight falcons jets close out week two
of the preseason dan lewis riddick steve
levy laura rutledge on the call that's
at eight eastern on espn you can also
catch dan on nfl live weekdays
at uh 4 eastern
you're all in on the denver broncos
i have been you know like there's a
reason why dan so
when do you remember
about i don't know 16 months ago now the
2021 draft draft day adam schefter comes
on live aaron rodgers reportedly unhappy
in green bay wants out and so
live tv you're like man
okay where where and i immediately it
was like the denver broncos
they got a defense that's top five they
got really good young talented skill
position people it's a roster that at
the quarterback goes there they could be
a really good team well obviously roger
stays in green bay russell gets traded
and it's very still very much so a
similar situation this is a defense
that's got the the talent to be a top 10
unit if bradley chubb stays healthy you
know on the outside with the addition of
randy gregory so they got two guys that
are high-end potentially elite pass
rushers they got a secondary that is
awesome led by patrick certain junior so
you're sitting there defensively that's
a top 10 defense and then offensively
the skill talent offensively really
really good better i don't want to say
skill talent is better than what russell
had in seattle but it's not all that far
off and then
nathaniel hackett brings over this
offensive scheme that you know has
really taken the league by storm in the
last two years and that's the mike
shanahan kyle shanahan
you know offensive scheme that's built
on the run game and everything looking
the same
and my point is you got a top 10 defense
and you got an offensive to offensive
situation russell wilson's never had
both
really good skill talent and really good
offensive scheme at the same time
and i think that
we're in this era in the nfl a little
bit where teams defensively are going to
force you to play the way that you don't
want to necessarily you know with the
whole two-high shell patch from homes on
i think they're the one offense in that
division that i feel really good because
of the scheme
to sit there and say listen if if teams
are gonna force you to run it 40 times
they are willing and able to run it 40
times to win games and i don't feel that
way about the chargers because i've
never seen it i don't feel that way
about the chiefs because i've seen them
not do it and i don't feel that way
because the offensive line about las
vegas but somebody's going to be a
disappointment then in the afc west
yeah what team i mean
well i think that
i do not expect the raiders to be a
playoff team i think that the raiders
are going to be really good offensively
um but i do believe the back end of
their defense will will kind of be the
the falloff of their team
um
i think that this it could be that
division that gets three teams into the
playoffs i'm still really really really
high on the chiefs um but my my thing on
the chiefs would be this
um
they i think more than anybody maybe
them in green bay
are
going to be so dependent on their
rookies playing really really high-end
football i mean mcduffie their corner
who's either going to play outside or
nickel inside is going to have to play
high-end ball because
tarvarius ward went to san francisco who
is their best cover guy okay i'm not
discrediting tehran matthew not being
there i know justin reed's going to be
really good but don't even leader their
defense
they don't have two edge rushers george
karlaftis is gonna have to be like tj
watt essentially and i don't know if
he's gonna be that guy you know so
um well i'm really high in the chiefs
still i just don't i i think that i like
the broncos defense better
it's been a while since we've had a
repeat champion you have to go back to
the patriots and o3 uh the reason why
the rams will not repeat
is
um
the secondary won't be as tied to the
front as they have been
you know um two years ago aubry pleasant
was their defensive backs coach he's no
longer there he wasn't there last year
either but they were really good tying
their coverage to their front that was
really good pass rush-wise
um his departure uh williams that
corners departure is going to stress
some of their younger players in the
secondary vaughn not being there is a
loss i still believe that they are the
team to beat along with the buffalo
bills for the super bowl but if they
don't it'll be because
that that unit um isn't as connected and
tied together as they they were last
year especially in the playoffs tom
brady missing a little more than a week
of practice reps um
what kind of impact
could that possibly i'm looking at the
schedule to start the season i mean that
nobody starts the season with a tougher
schedule than tampa bay but football
wise how do you think or this could
affect brady getting ready for the
season i think it's a bigger deal than
it's than it would have ever been
um because of the issues on their
offensive line inside right now that was
the story going into this season with
them is okay well both guards are gone
let's not pretend that that's not a big
deal
and then our center tears his acl that's
a huge deal for every quarterback i
don't care if you're the greatest of all
time
now the guy who's competing for the left
guard job tears his acl so the the
depletion of the health and the depth
and the high-end performance from their
offensive interior unit line wise
has been decimated and
the the the constant that brady has had
in tampa bay has been that five those
five guys up front it's the most con the
the they've played the most games
together in the nfl over the last two
years all we've done is picked out a
part and i i think the the issue is this
this pass game has to be different now
because you can't just assume that we're
going to play the same offense that we
were going to in may with all those
departed pieces and now injuries
and the easy answer is going to go with
tama get the ball out of his hands now
well then you're asking for guys like
mike evans and julio jones to be yards
after the catch guys
they're like take the short throw and
make it into the long one that's not who
they are certainly that's not who mike
is and it's not who julio is at his age
right now and i think like tom
trying to figure out the communication
with those guys up front the feel with
those guys up front them trying to learn
tom a little bit get on his same page
where he likes to be in the pocket
versus certain fronts and what's the
play call and
what's the drop and there's a lot that
goes into it and for them not to have
that with all these new pieces man it's
a big big deal
how often do you fall in love
during pre-season
i i fell in love again with tyler
huntley
yeah i i like him when he comes in he
makes plays and then i have to almost
smack myself into reality and say no the
ravens have a starting quarterback and
he's going to be the highest paid
quarterback in the nfl and tyler hunt
yeah how many times do you do that in
the course of a pre-season
yeah probably more in the past than i do
now i was having a conversation with
daniel jeremiah about this um obviously
nfl network and draft superstar all that
and he said something to me that kind of
really changed my thought process he was
like listen this is the the preseason
most of these guys should be playing
relatively well especially even nowadays
because of the way practice is
structured a lot of these games
are after you practicing with teams or
against teams for a couple days so you
have an even greater feel of what guys
are and what they want to do so he was
like
i don't ever try to get overly excited
about guys performing well because you
it's it's good to see
um but i think it's fair to be concerned
if guys are playing poorly and i think
that's kind of the mindset that i've
tried to adopt a little bit is and i've
said this like i've had preseason games
where you know i went 11 of 12 for 110
yards and a touchdown i'm like
what else do you need to see
i've had games when i've been five of 14
for 42 yards and interception so
um you know it's it's always good to see
guys playing well but
um i think it's to temper the
expectation of
thinking it's an easy transition from
going this player plays good in the
preseason to thinking he's going to do
that in the regular season over the
course of 17 games
i always wonder this that it feels like
you have to be talented to get to the
nfl to play quarterback now we have
varying degrees of talent uh you know
somebody showcases legs somebody's got a
really strong arm maybe you get the
combo platter there
but let me look at you and look at tom
brady
you're a better athlete than tom brady
you're you're faster you're faster
i ran a 6-2 in the 40 my sophomore year
of high school so
we're our speed is probably relatively
similar damn
yeah
man i'm sorry i ever tell you that i've
never shared this with you i'll i'll
make it quick because i know time is the
thing but
um this is this is when i got my first
scholarship offer i'm a junior in high
school with spring football and i'm
running right right in the world of like
a five five five six when i'm working
out with my dad training all that stuff
and i know i'm dead slow so randy edsel
was the head coach at uconn at the time
i did not have any offers at the time
recruiting's happening wants to come to
my spring practice and he's like hey
before practice i want to time you in
the 40. so i immediately know if i go
run 5-5 for uconn i'm not getting a
scholarship offer and i don't get
offered by uconn i'm not getting offered
by anybody right so forgive me here i
was a 16 year old junior in high school
whatever so we're down on the track
where our field is and our practice
fields are up top and i'm running
pre edsel getting there and it's 5 5 5 6
with my dad i'm like god bless dude this
is going to be awful so coach edsel
shows up and we're on the straight away
the track and his entrance to the field
is here so he shows up i've got a cone
here and a cone here right 40 yards
measured out my dad goes over to see him
and i'm on the back end the finish point
of the 40 and i see coach edsel and my
dad talking and in the moment i'm like
dude i got to do something so i walk up
to a cone the finish line cone and kick
it forward like three or four yards
honest to god's story three or four
yards coach hudson what's up nice to
meet you all that stuff i want to see
around the 40 around the 40. take off
four eight i run a four eight like 36
edsel watches practice i run 140 he
comes up watches practice
offers me after practice and the thing
takes off from there
so that's how i i cheated to give my
first scholarship offer in the 40s so
but if you don't get yukon
i don't you're not playing in the nfl
you might not even be right here 100
yeah because if if uconn wasn't going to
offer me then you know no other
bigger schools were going to offer me so
oh
man see kids this is a teaching moment
you know what you got to do you can make
your dreams come true by cheating people
and deceiving them and dan you've done a
great job in doing that i like you more
i can relate to you here i thought you
were a great athlete no no no no very i
mean i
i ran i think my vertical at the combine
was like 27 inches so it where i was i
was a good athlete pick up a ball be
good at anything but very unathletic
how would you do could kyler murray beat
you running backwards if you ran before
yeah easily my daughter i'm dead honest
my daughter is six
she's a
good she can she could beat me in a race
easily
could louis riddick beat you in a race
right now
how long's the race 40
36 yards 36 yards no no no i'm not gonna
give i will give louis this
i uh lewis fit like 53 years old he
looks like he's 43 but he's 53 years old
i think i could take him what about
laura rutledge
no god no
she'd get hurt
uh
the game is tonight it's the falcons and
the jets closing out week two coverage
begins at eight eastern on the
mothership great to talk to you dan
thank you
thanks legend appreciate you buddy
that's dan orlowski more phone calls
coming up we're back after this dan
patrick show